hey you heard anything about the new
captain uh no and I don't care I just
wish captain McGinley never left he was
the best it was terrible
just liked him cuz he let you do
anything you wanted what the hell's
going on around here
fire extinguisher roller chair Derby
okay what's your point I'm ever gonna
make captain I need a good mentor I need
my rabbi sorry dude but this new guy is
gonna be another washed-up pencil pusher
is only concerned with following every
rule and the patrol guide meet more
bleep robot captain engage is that what
you think hey new captain alert you must
be the new CEO I'm detective Jake
Peralta great to meet you
no don't let me interrupt you we're
describing what kind of person I'm gonna
be I'd like you to finish it's not
necessary
or I could recap very quickly sure um
let's see I think I said some joke about
a washed-up pencil pusher now did the
robot voice the robot voice you were
doing when you implied I'm a
rule-following robot I want to hear it
again sir robot that's a terrible robot
voice yep the next time I see you I'd
like you to be weighing a necktie Oh
actually the last captain didn't care if
we wore ties well your new captain does
and more importantly he cares that you
follow his direct orders everyone I'm a
new commanding officer captain ray Holt
speech that was sweet
you